it's day two of TGS 2018 and though we
wanted to shoot this video outside it is
absolutely miserable so we are inside
the hotel next to the convention center
and it's in the same place that we
actually had a chance to play it
definitely cry 5 which is the new game
in the series that Capcom's making
internally Tim you've played this before
correct yeah so I played at Gamescom and
it was specifically the Nero bill that
we played and I got to get to grips with
the basics of the game which one of you
plays games first time it kind of like
you never feel good playing it but it
kind of it started to click into place
there so elements of it that were kind
of confusing still like the devil
breaker is specifically it's taking some
getting used to it's it doesn't have the
kind of freedom of weapons working that
were used to from the Devil May Cry
games right so the system is I mean you
can speak it more yeah yeah I mean
playing as Nero I you know I did expect
a bit more fluidity both from his may
like melee attacks and his gun play he's
a little bit slow because he had the
focus is on his double breaker arms and
I think what frustrated me unfortunately
was the fact that even though you pick
up and can hold I think for double
breaker arms at least at the mission we
were playing you can't cycle through
them so if you have four and you want to
use say the second or third down the
slot you actually have to manually break
and get rid of the breakers you do have
now there are plenty of them to pick up
but it did feel a little disadvantageous
to not be able to say strategize and be
as fluid as I would be when playing say
as Dante yeah exactly so it's like you
said like were used to having these
options unlocked to us and then figuring
out how best to work them into our style
of play which isn't the case for Nero
but we played with Dante today and that
is very much the case with him and we
played quite and I think it was like a
build the way he had been his abilities
have been unlocked his latest stage
abilities yes and so it's a more souped
up Dante than perhaps we would usually
have at that stage of the game but then
you had the fluidity that we kind of I
wanted from Devil May Cry 3 he's back
with his Styles the kind of like trick
style and sword master gunslinger and
probably getting all these name
and Royal Guard but yeah and they're
like map to the d-pad and it's that kind
of satisfying finger gymnastics that you
need to do to make super slick combo so
I had a problem with my build away it
required me to play again a few times
and by the time I was finally done and
got like a one full playthrough I was
getting like s-rank kind of rankings for
each of my combat encounters and that
felt really good
that kind of momentum you build up and
moving around the environment that kind
of stuff that you get with Dante it's
exactly what you need and it felt good
[Applause]
of course you also have the ability to
swap between different melee weapons or
guns on the fly and that includes also a
motorcycle that Dante can rip in half
and use as dual blades yeah and it's
really distinct from the other weapons
the other weapons feel traditional like
the sword would feel and like the
gauntlets would feel this one is kind of
like a really long wind-up multi-hit
kind of like it is very very slow but it
like hits such a like a wide range of
enemies across such a massive like field
yeah and like traps than within this
attack so it's like a really good like
way to kind of build up your combo gauge
but also take some pressure off to give
you some time to think which is what I
was doing using it to kind of like give
me time to think of what style I need to
switch to next yeah and it was often
like oh I need to go into kind of the
trick style so I can teleport to the
enemy and then use that again to fill
some time and then go out and even sort
master and then switch to that so I can
do air combos and that kind of stuff and
it was like it's a good kind of like
texture to the to the combat system
which is already feeling quite good that
kind of trapping mechanism almost it
feels real good to have that yeah like
it did feel really nice to swap between
all those different things on the fly
and had those options as you said that
thing this was mission 11 so very far
along and I felt maybe a little bit
unsure of what options I did have I came
across one of the little upgrade statues
where you can cash in your orbs and buy
new abilities and I realize like oh wait
they have unlocked all but one and I
forget how much it costs but it was far
more than I had unfortunately also
notice that there is an option to
purchase orbs with real-world money from
the Xbox Live Store in this case because
we were playing on xbox I'm sure the
same will be true on PSN and you know
this the old adage goes that it's really
up to the player if they really want to
take advantage of that but it felt a bit
strange to see that in a game like Devil
May Cry I never anticipated to see
microtransactions or Amelie yeah it's
you know player versus a computer but
pay to win yeah I think's the the the
implications that we were talking about
after seeing that was like it's quite an
overwhelming game mechanically the
abilities that you get they're all kind
of stack into on top of each other and
to be really good at the game you need
to be good at kind of using all of them
almost in quick succession and
figuring out on the fly which one to
bring in and which one to drop out and
you're not gonna get that if you just
buy it and then once you feel kind of
like I did which was a little bit lost I
imagine yeah exactly so like I it took
me a bunch of playthroughs of the demo
to figure out how all the styles are
best to transition between and like you
said if you're just buying those items
and abilities from the outset do you
kind of like bypass the part of the game
that kind of teaches you and has the
time set out for you to have this you
know it's it's paced in a way that you
only have this ability and you'll spend
an hour figuring that out before another
one becomes available feasibly so it's
it's a weird interest and interesting
but like weird design choice that I
expected your unexpected and I'm
interested in seeing how it kind of like
on falls in the implications that has on
my overall experience yeah I hope it's I
hope it doesn't skew the experience cuz
I'm not going to take advantage of that
if I don't have to yeah and I do look
forward to playing this game to see what
it's really about cuz it's it's fun to
see the old style definitely cry
attitude and sort of aesthetic come back
of course I really loved what Newser
theory did with the series as well then
I don't mind having those two styles of
DMC live in parallel but of course Nero
is like a big question mark for me his
double breaker system is promising I
like that one of them I could ride
around like a hoverboard and the enemies
which is super surprising but again I
still have some reservations about the
way that you go through the different
Dublin breakers so clearly there's a lot
we still have to find out in the Devil
May Cry and there's a third character as
well like Dante feels great and like two
fields as you to feel from the Devil May
Cry 3 but there's a third character that
is kind of like an x-factor
perhaps as well so it's gonna be cool to
see what becomes of him they keep saying
that he's very different from the other
characters in this game and in previous
games in the series well obviously
there's still a lot of time between now
and the eventual release Tate in 2019 I
definitely look forward to seeing more
of the game Tim I'm sure I can speak for
you and say yes so I've played it a
bunch and we have a gameplay video up of
it in which I get an overall rank of s
which I'm very proud of for my first
time we've Dante so check that out and
yeah you can find us meanwhile on
Twitter I'm at more aged PC Brown come
and talk to us about Devil May Cry and
we dudes with white hair which is done
if in case you're wondering I know anger
out there